sous une robe sûr sensation
bonjour et bienvenue dans un europe /
sensation une émission enregistrée au
parlement européen de bruxelles est
réalisée en association avec tv 78 voici
le sommaire de ce nouveau numéro
l'eurodéputé caroline rousse sera notre
invité l'occasion de revenir avec elle
sur les engagements pris à la coop 26 de
glasgow ce jour là le 15 juin 1987
adoption du programme erasmus par le
conseil des ministres de l'éducation
européen les superstitions en europe
avec evelyne keller auteur du livre 300
une superstition celle opportun on
s'intéressera aux superstitions liées
aux chats qui n'ont pas toujours eu une
mauvaise réputation mais avant que fait
l'europe dans notre région un exemple
tout de suite
zone europe l'europe dans ma région
me voilà dans le village les a lus et le
roi dans le département des yvelines est
aujourd'hui je vais découvrir les
secrets de la confection des yaourts y
est pour cela je vais à la rencontre de
flavien c'est parti pour occuper
s'entraîner dans le labo il faut que tu
mettes un kit visiteurs composés d'une
blouse d'une charlotte de sur chaussures
et bien sûr d'un masque salut benoît
alors comme ça c'est toi qui détient la
recette des fameux yaourt étape numéro
un la ferme c'est là-bas que le livreur
récupère le lait pour le collectés dans
la citerne il sera ensuite vidé dont le
pasteurisateur pendant près de deux
heures et à 80° le lait va être
pasteurisé afin de tuer toutes les
bactéries l'étape suivante c'est la
chambre chaude puis l'enrobage le lait
devenu plus solide et placés dans des
bassines pour la fermentation une fois
cette étape validée le yaourt est
basculée dans du linge d'égouttage où il
restera deux à trois heures c'est
presque la fin la texture est brassée
avec une girafe afin de lui rendre son
aspect crémeux et onctueux
combien de kilos ça représente à chaque
fois puisque vous avez une bassine de
250 kg donc on va me faire à peu près de
2400 peau afin qu'il est brassée on va
remplir la trémie de
de là conditionneuse pour pouvoir leur
entière est conditionné en pot
joie
l'équipe de benoit reçu un fonds de
soutien européen qui lui a permis de
financer en partie une confectionneuse à
double entrée pour améliorer la
production mais ce n'est pas tout les
asservir également à agrandir notre
flambeau froide donc là on a installé
une nouvelle chambre froide de 70 m²
pour les collectivités qui n'ont comme à
25000 peau non point pour le voir à
l'avance des commandes comme on a
quarante jours de dlc stocker puis ce
fut tendu vient de sortir du laboratoire
vous venez de découvrir la confection
des yaourts y ici dans les yvelines
juste derrière moi il y à cet entrepôt
là également il ya la nouvelle grande
chambre froide financés par le fonds de
soutien européen
mais dans cet entrepôt il y avait
également l'ancienne boutique elle était
trop petit et donc maintenant il ya une
nouvelle boutique qui se trouve juste de
l'autre côté alors cela vient ici c'est
le comptoir de la grange est ce que tu
peux nous expliquer pourquoi c'est une
boutique on a lancé en 2018 pour mettre
en valeur l'ensemble des produits
français vient on à du fromage de la
charcuterie des produits d'épicerie des
desserts frais des tartines l'équipe de
benoît a reçu de nombreuses récompenses
en 2015 médaille d'or au concours
général agricole en 2016 victoire au
concours patrimoine francilien mais il
ya aussi l'entrée au salon international
de l'alimentaire une vraie référence
pour les tendances alimentaires la
tendance y
sonos robe ce jour là
ce jour là c'est le 15 juin 1987
l'adoption du programme erasmus par le
conseil des ministres de l'éducation
européen retour avec europe direct vous
connaissez certainement le european
bridge en actions ce qui me for mobility
of university students si vous vous
attardez affaires l'acronyme de selon
titre vous avez erasmus mais oui vous le
connaissez si vous questionnez les gens
dans votre entourage parmi vos proches
ou vos amis vous trouverez sûrement
quelqu'un qui a bénéficié de la bourse
erasmus si ce n'est pas vous même tout
le monde connaît en effet ce programme
qui avait eu et qui a encore vocation à
construire l'europe il a été créé le 15
juin 1987 et c'est la marque de fabrique
de lieux le nom est inspiré du
théologien erasme de rotterdam qui a
beaucoup voyagé en europe pour
s'enrichir des différentes cultures
erasmus plus a été conçu pour que les
jeunes gagnent en compétences en partant
dans un autre pays membres pour étudier
et ensuite après la réforme pour y
travailler aussi l'idée c'est qu'ils
augmentent leur employabilité après
avoir effectué cette expérience de
formation qui est reconnue au sein de
tout lieu le projet avoue le a vu le
jour grâce à sofia corradi professeur de
nationalité italienne qui s'est battu
pour la reconnaissance des diplômes
entre les pays européens puisqu'ils
n'avaient pas eu la même chance selon la
commission européenne
en 2007 c'est à dire 30 ans après sa
création 9 millions d'européens auraient
bénéficié de la bourse erasmus plus
aujourd'hui 33 pays permet à ceux qui
sont éligibles de partir dans un autre
pays adhérents pour étudier faire une
expérience de stage ou professionnels
alors de deux semaines à un an en plus
ces races mu plus à démocratiser la
mobilité c'est une expérience pour
toutes les poches puisque les bourses
allant de 300 à 450 euros par mois
permettent de couvrir une partie
importante de dépenses qu'attendez vous
donc si vous ne l'avez pas encore fait
chercher l'organisme dans va le plus
proche de chez vous pour commencer cette
aventure européenne ce sera peut-être
l'auberge espagnole mais tant mieux vous
aurez contribué à la construction de
l'europe
zone europe l'invité politique
bonjour carole une rose bonjour vous
êtes eurodéputés membres du groupe des
verts au parlement européen
et aujourd'hui nous allons revenir sur
la coque 26 cette grande conférence
internationale sous l'égide des nations
unies sur les conséquences du changement
climatique qui s'est tenue à glasgow
cette année quel bilan vous en avez tiré
alors j'en fais pas un un bon bilan
puisque pour moi c'est un accord au
rabais
aujourd'hui au vu du changement
climatique avec ce qui se passe à
l'heure actuelle il faudrait courir
alors on va dans le bon sens mais en
fait des petits pas en avant alors qu'il
faudrait courir donc pour moi
aujourd'hui c'est un accord au rabais
beaucoup de médias ont présenté cette
coop comme celle de la dernière chance
est-ce que ils en ont trop fait ou est
ce que au contraire vous partager cette
vision ben je dirais que soit ils en ont
trop fait
parce que pour moi que je vous le disais
c'est un accord au rabais c'est quand
même inquiétant de voir qu'aujourd'hui
il ya un fossé qui se creuse entre les
engagements et la réalité on est parti
au niveau de l'ambition de l'union
européenne de 65%
de réduction d'émissions de gaz à effet
de serre d'ici 2030
l'union européenne a pour objectif une
baisse maintenant de 55 % d'ici 2030
ensuite il ya un collectif la convention
citoyenne pour le climat qui a travaillé
sur 40% et ensuite ça a été rabotée donc
on en fait on a démarré à 65 % 55 % puis
40 et puis finalement ça encore été
rabotée donc on est vraiment loin des 65
% il ya quand même quelques avancées mis
en avant notamment lors de cette coop 80
pays ont désormais la neutralité carbone
dans leur objectif soit 13 de plus
qu'avant la conférence de glasgow plus
de 100 pays ont accepté de réduire leurs
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
2030 or c'est quand même un pas en avant
c'est encore trop insuffisant c'est
encore trop insuffisant puisque comme je
voulais 10 entre 65% et moins de 40% on
est vraiment très très loin du compte
pour plus de 120 pays reprises qu'ils
représentent environ 90% des forêts du
monde se sont engagés à stopper et à
inverser la déforestation d'ici 2030 là
encore c'est une bonne chose ou c'est
trop peu en disant que pour moi c'est
insuffisant je suis sceptique sur ce qui
s'est dit puisque je me dis qu'il ya
quelques années on en parlait déjà pour
moi c'est une schizophrénie de notre
politique commerciale sur la
déforestation on importe la
déforestation donc à un moment donné je
pense que des paroles il faut arriver
aux actes qu'est-ce qui aurait selon
vous aurait dû être prise comme
engagement lors de cette coupe 26 pour
faire avancer les ambitions concernant
le climat mais ce qui a coincé c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on est sur une situation
d'injustice climatique c'est les pays
les plus riches qui polluent le plus au
détriment des pays en développement
alors que
bassetto qui polluent le moins et c'est
eux qui sont plus d'impact et
aujourd'hui est donc pour moi il ya une
grosse injustice climatique vous avez
été rapporte rice fictive des verts sur
les aspects de développement de cette
coque 26 en quoi est ce qu a consisté ce
travail que vous avez fait ce travail
justement il
et en commissions développement il a
permis de mettre en lumière le fait que
les pays en développement
aujourd'hui sont très impactées par
cette crise climatique
mais ce n'est pas eux qui est
aujourd'hui ils sont les pollueurs c'est
les gros pays riches en fait et donc
j'ai mis ça en avant sur sur mon rapport
en commission développement le
développement se fait primordiale pour
cette lutte oui mais elle et elle est
primordiale pour cette lutte pour le
climat il faut savoir qu'ils ont besoin
d'avoir des fonds pour l'adaptation au
climat et justement aujourd'hui sont
très impactées par rapport à la
sécheresse climatique on va avoir des
déplacés climatiques et tout ça je pense
que c'est les pays en développement
aujourd'hui qui sont en première ligne
par rapport à ça une nouvelle coop
devrait être organisée en 2022 quels
seront alors les enjeux pour l'année
prochaine les mêmes que ceux qui ont
sont produits cette année bah j'espère
qu'il y aura beaucoup plus d'enjeu et
que ce sera plus contraignant que la
coop d'aujourd'hui qui pour moi
bah était
une clope au rabais donc j'aimerais bien
qu'on aille vers des engagements qui
soit contraignant et peut-être si
présent la république en 2002 sera
président de gauche ou écologistes
peut-être que ça permettra de faire
avancer les choses on pense que oui je
pense bien oui il faut des écologistes
aux pauvres en allemagne justement les
écologistes sont désormais au
gouvernement dans une coalition avec les
sociaux-démocrates et libéraux alors
comment est ce que vous avez accueilli
cette nouvelle alors gelé très bien
accueilli cette nouvelle parce que
justement il faudrait au gouvernement
beaucoup plus d'écolo en france bientôt
scellé la présidentielle on aimerait
bien qu'ils aient un écolo président en
france
on sait que en ce qui concerne
l'allemagne on obtient plusieurs
ministères on obtient le ministère de
l'écologie de l'économie et du climat
les ministères de la famille le
ministère de l'environnement et de la
protection des consommateurs on aimerait
bien avoir encore plus mais c'est déjà
un grand pas en avant
la nouvelle coalition annoncé une sortie
accélérée du charbon notamment on
imagine que c'est une annonce qui vous
réjouit ah oui ca me réjouis beaucoup
une sortie du charbon en 2030 ça serait
bien que au sein de l'union européenne
on est en haïssant la même direction man
est encore un petit peu loin mais c'est
une bonne avancée cette nouvelle
coalition qu'elle vous permets ici au
parlement européen de de finalement
d'avoir plus de poids maintenant que les
allemands seront devenus entre
guillemets un peu plus écologiste ben on
va s'atteler justement dans les
commissions et dans les groupes à ce que
on soit beaucoup plus d'écologistes il
faut qu'on soit beaucoup plus ambitieux
quant au carbone quant à la protection
du climat à l'environnement la
déforestation il faut comtois vraiment
plus ambitieux dans le cadre de vos
activités d'eurodéputés enfin vous êtes
mobilisés pour défendre le requin mako
parce que vous pouvez nous présenter
cette espèce alors c'est une espèce de
requin
qui est sans danger pour l'humain ils
attaquent rarement l'humain le précise
parce que quand on voir qu'un dit oh mon
dieu quel suspense c'est un requin qui
se développent très peu en fait il a une
reproduction qui est très mince et donc
aujourd'hui il en voie d'extinction et
ont demandé à ce qu'il y ait plus de
capture de deux requins mako
on est arrivé à force de d'inclure la
société civile les ong à faire pression
sur la commission et on a obtenu
certaines avancées pour se re kamako qui
sont pour moi insuffisante mais qui je
ne peux pas je ne peux pas dire que
c'est fait c'est pas bien c'est une
première victoire et on va continuer à
suivre le sujet sur le rocamadour
comment est ce que vous êtes vous avez
fait pour vous mobiliser pour essayer
d'influencer sur l'édition de la
commission notamment là ils m'ont
entendu très souvent j'ai suivi toutes
les négociations si j'étais pas présente
mais équipes suivent et les négociations
pour mettre la pression à la commission
on a reçu les ong et il faut vraiment
que cette espèce elle soit
qu'elles reviennent et qu'elle puisse se
reproduire tranquillement son qui est
des surpêche on sait qu'il ya un enjeu
commercial sur les requins mako mais à
un moment donné s'il ya plus de pression
il ya plus l'enjeu commercial et puis
voilà le record mac os qu'il a d'autres
espèces qui sont dans votre montre votre
viseur en ce moment
soutenir ce que vous retrouverez dans
les petites boîtes de thon le thon
albacore qui est en grand danger
malheureusement on donne encore des
quotas pour ce pour ce cette espèce là
et ça c'est un gros problème pour moi
merci beaucoup heureuse d'avoir été avec
nous tous en europe je rappelle que vous
êtes députée européenne au sein du
groupe des verts au parlement européen
merci à vous en europe
et chez nos voisins ça se passe comment
c'est notre rubrique en partenariat avec
a choisi l'institut des hautes études de
journalisme de montpellier et chez nos
voisins ça se passe comment le cannabis
le cannabis est une substance
psychoactive très prisé en france elle
était consommée par près de 13 millions
de français en 2012 plaçant le pays au
premier rang européen de consommation
régulière de cannabis en 2018 illégale à
la consommation et à la détention depuis
1970 ce n'est cependant pas le cas de
tous les pays en effet nos pays
frontaliers n'ont pas le même avis quant
à la consommation du cannabis en
allemagne par exemple il est vendu en
pharmacie à des fins thérapeutiques
et c'est à des tensions et légal jusqu'à
15 grammes selon les régions aussi cette
année le luxembourg est devenu le
premier pays européen à légaliser le
kanak le cannabis récréatif au sein du
domicile la culture du cannabis à
domicile est désormais tolérée jusqu'à
quatre plans par foyer
néanmoins le gouvernement luxembourgeois
interdit toujours la consommation du
cannabis en public mais instaure une
procédure pénale allégée pour les
personnes fumant à l'extérieur de leur
domicile désormais ils risqueront
jusqu'à 145 euros damende comment parler
de cannabis sans évoquer les pays bas
contrairement aux croyances communes la
politique néerlandaise en matière de
drogue n'est pas aussi laxiste que ce
que l'on croit en effet toutes les
drogues sont interdites aux pays-bas
toutefois le gouvernement a conçu une
politique relative au cannabis
autorisant sa consommation dans des
lieux prévus à cet effet appelé les
coffee shops soumis à des règles très
strictes ils sont inaccessibles aux
mineurs et ne peuvent pas délivré plus
de 5 grammes par jour et par personne
toutes ces décisions de la légalisation
à la tolérance ont toutes le même but
réduire la demande de drogues qui
influent sur le taux de délinquance
ainsi les institutions gouvernementales
peuvent se concentrer sur les vrais
criminels qui importe et vente des
drogues dures
soon europe voyage
on en vient maintenant à notre rubrique
voyager dans l'assiette une nouvelle
recette tout de suite je suis chef
robert je tienne le reste lente lille a
créé hogan un changement ne l'est
aujourd'hui jeu va vous montrer le faon
devions tuer une flatterie tu piques
suédois qui est lâche est plutôt est
ce qu'on va dire une plaque quotidienne
qui - jeu a revisité armand vaillancourt
aurait être plus adapté à la
restauration dont la recette on a le
viande hachée des oignons des carottes
des pleurotes et et on utilise aussi une
appareil avec deux chapelets des oeufs
et de claire pour avec ça on va réaliser
une
ketchup de betteraves et framboises et
pour ça il ne faut des oignons doux et
le framboise de betteraves et du tout
mais on va commencer à préparer le
baisse de leurs recettes qui est le pont
de vianne soi même on a raison de tendre
le cas selon dans le poêlon naître les
unes peu d'huile pour faire revenir la
baule
les sogno
et on m'a laissé on laisserait les
oignons et puis un peu coup devenu une
petit peu
plus mou qui les carottes c'est le plus
bas c'est cela qui est le plus dur
en puissant quoi bon
et voilà on est des oignons
et appelait avec ça on plante de une
petite peau du foie blé pois bleu noir
comme cas c'est
maintenant on va laisser ça et
bien ceci avant on mettra les pleurotes
le plus gros de films entaché
dans sa non les oignons et le
[Musique]
les carottes est saisie on a notre
viande hachée dans un cul-de-poule on
ajoute à on ajoute le apparaît avec de
chapelure des oeuvres et du clem on
ajouterait une petite
vaisselle
voilà on peut mettre en poney de maître
de l'europe
il faut le bien cessé jusqu'à ce qu'ils
se réduit à peu près à la moitié que les
oignons et les carottes ils sont plus de
kilos compte qu'ils sont bien des
gens deviennent bout et que les
pleurotes a pris une toute petit peu de
colonnes et ensuite pour réaliser leurs
tubes et rap framboise comprendre un peu
d'huile de tournesol
on laisse ça chauffe bien
[Musique]
on a essayé ces deux
les betteraves les framboises les
tomates du balsamique et moi j'utilise
produits suédois c2c le sucre et de
mélasse on s'est dit mais là ce sucre 2
deux bêtes a su
quand les oignons commence à colorer et
c'est bien un concept bien chaud dans la
poêle on ajoutera le sucre
voir
[Musique]
conde quand le sucre à bien car me
laisser ont des glaces au vinaigre
balsamique
on ajoute notre framboises les
betteraves
les tomates
et on les saluer avec avec un petit peu
de poivre
et du sel
et maintenant quand notre
dose mélange du bureau et de leurs
oignons de 40 est prêt
à mélenchon
ça ensemble avec nous apparaît à chaque
lot
clem et des heures
après on ne mélange
salamandre
[Musique]
et voilà on à la patte qu'il faut
[Applaudissements]
après contre la pâte
le mélange de lyon mathieu et ça c'est
bien
et c'est pour ça on appelle ça le pan
devions après contre la pâte
les mélanges de viande hachée et ça
c'est bien
et c'est pour ça on appelle ça le podium
rappelons valeurs entourées avec les
l'amf humain
on m
en 2000 dans une plaque pour le four
on le mettrait le pain de viande
et on va mettre ça au four à 175 degrés
pour environ 35 40 minutes
et comme
quand les katchou
accueilli jusqu'à ce qu'ils les oignons
les oignons les betteraves et viennent
me viennent bien compris on est très
sage dans ce mix remix l'on met dans le
blender et on ajoute les goûts les sel
et le poivre l'eau ce qui ce qui peut
manquer selon le logo plus con c'est
bienne réduit on est très sage entendu
dans le blender
hourra
[Applaudissements]
après qu'on a passé le notre ketchup
dans le bundle on a on a vérifié que le
goût il ne voit ici on le mettrait dans
une bouteille pour pouvoir faire des
décorations sur les assiettes aussi
semble pour vous d acheter
une bouteille si vous voulez faire route
des salins
pour le dressage on utilise notre
bouteille on peut faire une petite
c'était les âges comme ça
[Applaudissements]
on place le par mu en ondes une petite
seconde
et avec ça pour le petit couleurs et
pour faire un petit peu plus festif on
met le petite salle
quelques petit concombre nerfs
et voilà c'est ça le le pain de viande
suédois
sous drogue sur sensations
les superstitions en europe avec evelyne
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition petite encyclopédie des
peurs et sagesse populaire celle
opportun on s'intéresse cette semaine au
chat le char si on regarde bien
l'histoire du chant dans l'antiquité
c'était un animal vénérer les égyptiens
on avait fait une ds alors que nous
pour certains la crainte c'est justement
de croiser un chat est un chat noir
cette crainte du chat noir elle va
remonter au moyen âge on en faisait la
tribu des sorcières donc doublement
porte malheur
alors le chat à accoter porte bonheur et
porte malheur le côté porte bonheur on
dit qu'un chat à sept ou neuf vies
donc en se basant sur cette longévité du
chat avoir h à la maison est un porte
bonheur
d'ailleurs les orientaux ont souvent à
l'entrée de leur commerce achat comme
petit animal qui apporte la chambre dans
la maison zone europe c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui merci aux équipes techniques
du parlement européen de bruxelles vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission podcast
audio et vidéo sur notre site et notre
application radio sensations et aussi
sur tv soixante dix huit rendez vous la
semaine prochaine très bonne soirée à
toutes et à tous
sonos robe sûr sensation
zone europe avec le soutien financier de
la région ile de france